What if I told you that your job title, like the actual thing printed on your business card, is probably going to die in the next five years, but the actual work you do every day is going to survive just fine?
I think that's a pretty wild premise to start with, but yeah, it's highly likely. We have this habit of treating a job title like a permanent identity.
Right, exactly. You get a label that says accountant or copywriter, and you just assume that label is this sturdy box protecting your whole career.
Yeah, and society categorizes the labor market that way, mostly because it's – mentally convenient for us.
But today we are going to look at why employers aren't actually changing your job in the age of artificial intelligence. They are literally just deleting it entirely. So welcome to the deep dive.
Glad to be here.
Our mission today is to figure out what an occupation actually is beneath the surface. Like, is it that title or is it a shifting hidden matrix of tasks and requirements? And to get to the bottom of this, we are looking at a completely groundbreaking new paper.
Yeah, it was just posted to our cock a few days ago on August 27, 2026. Right.
And it's by Chin Chen, Ying Feng, Zhang Yu Wang and Leo Yang Yang. It's called The Pulse Beneath the Job title.
And I have to say, the scope of what they've done is truly staggering. They've essentially built a real-time, month-by-month MRI for the entire Chinese labor market.
We also brought a stack of classic labor economics papers to the table, foundational work by economists like Otter, Adelaide, Frey, and Osborne, and Ilundo.
Right, because what this new paper found completely clashes with decades of established theory, which we will definitely get into.
Oh, we will. But to start us off, I mean, I have to ask about the sheer scale of the data here. If you want to know what's happening to the molecular structure of a job, how do you even begin to measure that?
Well, you measure it by analyzing the exact language employers use when they are desperate to hire someone.
OK, so job ads.
Exactly. Between January 2020 and June 2026, these researchers scraped 752.6 million job ads.
Wait, 750 million. That's insane.
Right. They pulled these from the top five recruitment platforms in China. It's roughly 1.8 terabytes of raw text, which they then deduplicated down to 116 million totally unique job descriptions.
I'm just trying to wrap my head around 116 million unique descriptions. That means they aren't just looking at the generic word marketing assistant.
No, not at all. They're looking at every single variation, you know, every weird list of bullet points a hiring manager just threw together on a Friday afternoon across the entire country.
That's incredible.
It is. And historically, researchers have analyzed job postings using proprietary data sets that rely on like skill keywords.
Right. Like searching for the word Excel or whatever.
Yeah. But the problem is a keyword is a conflation. It blends everything together. What this team did instead was split the language of the job ads into two highly specific separate objects.
Requirements and tasks.
Exactly. So
break that down for me. Why is separating those two things so critical?
Because they represent two entirely different sides of the transaction. Requirements are the conditions you, the candidate, must satisfy before you even walk in the door.
So it's what you must be or have.
Right. Degrees, specific licenses, years of experience, or even a willingness to travel. The researchers actually cataloged 20,721 distinct requirement items spread across 16 top-level classes. Wow.
Okay. And what about the tasks?
Tasks are the things you will actually do once you are hired. And to track these, the researchers built this really fascinating matrix.
Oh, I love a good matrix. How does it work?
They took 32 broad business domains.
Like what?
Things like client acquisition or logistics. And they crossed those with 26 action modes, like data entry, troubleshooting, or negotiation. So it's a giant grid. A grid with 832 possible cells. And they found that 698 of those cells are
actively occupied by real tasks out in the wild.
Which gives them, what, like tens of thousands of unique tasks?
44,479 unique tasks, to be exact. So between the requirements and the tasks, they mapped 65,200 catalog items under 12.1 billion mentions across all those job ads.
Okay, hold on. If they are using large language models to parse and categorize 116 million unique job ads, the computing cost for that would be astronomical.
Oh, absolutely.
Like if I asked an AI to read and categorize 100 million documents, I'd go bankrupt. How did they actually afford to do this?
This is honestly the methodological heartbeat of the whole paper. It's just a masterclass in cost discipline. Because you're right, naively running every single one of those job ads through a commercial LLM to classify them would have cost roughly 9.7 million yuan per 100 million titles.
Yeah, that's completely prohibitive.
So they spent that expensive AI judgment exclusively on building reusable artifacts, taxonomies, cluster boundaries, compiled regular expressions.
Oh, I see. So instead of paying the AI to categorize every single ad, they use the AI to build the rules and then use cheaper traditional computing to sort the ads based on those rules.
That's a perfect way to visualize it. They asked the AI to adjudicate vocabulary boundary pairs.
Give me an example of that.
So they would feed the model two terms from the wild, like client maintenance and equipment maintenance. Then they asked the model, are these the same underlying task, just phrased differently?
And the model obviously says no.
Right. They did this for about 520,000 pairs, essentially mapping the entire structure of the language, but only doing the heavy lifting once.
OK, I love this. It's like instead of paying an artisan baker to hand cut 100 million individual cookies, you pay a lot of money once to 3D print an indestructible perfect cookie cutter. Exactly. And then you just stamp it out mechanically. So what was the
final cost to build the cookie cutter?
About 3 to 300 yuan.
From 9.7 million down to 3,300. That's just wild. But does the taxonomy built on the cheap actually hold up? Like, is it accurate?
It holds up brilliantly. We know this because they validated their results against the current gold standard. They compared their occupation level AI exposure scores against the rubric built by Taina Alondo and her team.
the famous OpenAI paper.
Yeah, and the correlation was very strong between 0.73 and 0.79. It proves they are measuring the exact same phenomenon just at a microscopic month-by-month resolution.
So now we have this high definition camera pointing at the labor market. What does it actually reveal when we look at everyday jobs? Let's take something incredibly standard like an accountant.
Right. So if you look at the national average for an accountant, you get one generic profile. But when you apply this new data set, it reveals a massive hidden staircase inside that single job title based on the wage band.
Let me guess. The entry-level accountant isn't doing the same things as the senior accountant.
Far from it. In the lowest posted wage band, 68% of an accountant's daily task mentions are just core bookkeeping. Just raw data entry and ledger balancing.
Makes sense. And at the top.
When you move to the highest wage band for the exact same job title, core bookkeeping drops to 49%. It gets displaced by complex compliance work and data analysis.
And I imagine the requirements to even get that job change drastically too, right?
They do. The demand for specific certificates nearly doubles as you move up the wage bands, jumping from 28% to about 52%. The title on the door says accountant in both cases, but the internal DNA of the job has been entirely swapped
out.
Now, I'd assume that kind of internal variation happens with almost every profession. You know, you get paid more, your tasks change.
You would think so, but the data says no. Take a Java developer as the counterexample.
Okay, what happens there?
For a Java developer, the bundle of software and algorithmic tasks is almost identical at every single experience level.
Wait, really?
Yeah. And those certificates that matter so much to accountants. For Java developers, they barely register. They are only requested in three to five percent of postings.
So for a Java developer, the national average actually is a good representation of the job. It's a flat line. But for an accountant, the average is just a statistical illusion hiding a staircase.
Which is exactly why having this task level data is so vital. You cannot manage a workforce or a career if you don't know whether you are dealing with a staircase or a flatline.
Let's apply this to a space where policymakers are heavily focused right now, which is blue collar automation. If I think about a production worker on an assembly line, I'm assuming they are pretty safe from large language models. I mean, AI isn't going to turn
a wrench for you.
At the entry level, you are entirely correct. The mean LLM exposure for low-wage production workers is below 0.2 on their index. It's highly physical. Right. But let's look at the postings offering 20,000 to 50,000 yuan a month. The
AI exposure for those specific production workers spikes to 0.48.
Wait, 0.48? Why would a highly paid factory worker be more exposed to an AI that analyzes text?
Because at 50,000 yuan a month, you aren't turning a wrench anymore. The job ads for that wage band focus heavily on quality documentation, data recording, and process coordination.
Oh, wow. So you are managing the information about the assembly line, not the physical line itself.
Exactly. And managing information is exactly what language models excel at.
I mean, that is a massive blind spot for policymakers. You know, you look at a chart, see production worker and assume that whole bucket of humans is safe. But the highest earners in that bucket are actually sitting right in the crosshairs of automation.
And this ties into a larger aggregate drift across the entire Chinese labor market over this 32 month period. Employers are subtly demanding different things in aggregate.
What kind of things?
Well, posted work is scoring higher on being on site. a bump of plus .06 on their index. It is becoming more embodied, more consequence supervised, and more credential gated.
Hold on, slow down. Consequence supervised? What does that actually mean for a human being walking onto a factory floor?
It means the employer isn't just supervising the process of how you do the work. They are supervising the outcome or the consequence of
it. Like quality control?
Right, or safety inspections. It requires human judgment in a physical space. The overall market is drifting away from the pure text and analysis work that an LLM can do and shifting toward work that requires a human body in a physical location being held
accountable for physical results.
OK, so if the broader market is drifting away from AI vulnerable work, what is actually happening to the specific jobs that are highly exposed? You know, the data entry clerks, the translators, the copywriters.
This brings us to the headline tension of the entire paper. Because this data set tracks both layers simultaneously, the researchers measured the decline of demand at the occupation layer and the task layer at the same time.
Okay, what did they find at the occupation layer?
At the occupation layer, jobs highly exposed to LLMs are losing posting share incredibly fast. The slope of decline is negative 1.33.
Meaning HR departments are just posting far fewer ads for those vulnerable titles.
But here is the twist. When you look at the task layer, the broad categories of work that make up those jobs, those specific tasks, are losing share much, much slower. The slope there is only negative 0.83.
That's a huge gap. The job titles are vanishing much faster than the daily work itself. Why is that happening?
To figure out why, the researchers used something called a shift share decomposition and a three-component Shepley decomposition.
Okay. For those of us who aren't labor economists, how does that math actually work?
Think of it like trying to figure out why your grocery bill went down. Did your bill drop because you bought smaller boxes of cereal? Or did it drop because you stopped buying cereal entirely and bought cheap oatmeal instead?
Oh, I see.
The decomposition mathematically separates the size of the occupations from the ingredients inside the occupations.
So they're asking, are high exposure tasks disappearing because employers are rewriting the job descriptions to remove them or simply because employers are killing the occupations altogether?
The math is definitive. The entire gradient of decline runs through the posting share channel. That specific variable, the beta, is negative 0.79.
So what does that mean in plain English?
It means that high exposure tasks are losing ground only because the occupations carrying them are shrinking.
So if I'm a manager and I have a copywriter whose job is now 50% automated by AI, I'm not keeping the copywriter title and just assigning them new non-AI strategy tasks.
You aren't. The within-occupation mixed channel, meaning the rate at which employers are quietly stripping exposed tasks out of surviving jobs, is negative .02. It's essentially zero. Wow.
So employers are not rewriting the jobs. They are just posting fewer of them.
Exactly. In fact, the number of task mentions per posting actually went up slightly by .05.
Let's unpack the corporate psychology behind that. Why is it easier for a company to just delete the copywriter requisition entirely rather than just ask the copywriter to do more strategy?
Mostly bureaucracy and signaling. If you fundamentally change the tasks a person does, HR usually has to reevaluate the role, change the pay band, retrain the employee.
That sounds exhausting for a manager.
It is. It is organizationally much easier to just freeze hiring for the old title, let attrition happen naturally, and open a brand new requisition for a content strategist.
Which leads to the central thesis of the paper.
The author's own sentence says it best. The tasks outlive the jobs that carry them.
the tasks outlive the jobs. That perfectly brings to mind the paper by Brynjolfsson, Chandar, and Chen that we have in our stack here. They looked at ADP payroll data, right?
Yes, and they found a 19% drop in employment for 22 to 25-year-olds in occupations highly exposed to AI.
Which lines up perfectly. Brynjolfsson's team proved that the demand for those roles is dropping in actual payrolls. This new paper from China explains the mechanism of how that adjustment happens on the front lines of hiring.
Exactly. It runs entirely through which jobs get posted, not by changing what the surviving ones contain.
Now, I need to pause here and issue a massive caveat for anyone listening. We are talking about job postings. This is a measure of posted demand, like an employer's wish list.
Right. This is not a count of finalized hires or total employment.
Furthermore, the authors are very explicit that these are descriptive gradients, not causal estimates. We see a strong association between AI exposure and shrinking job titles, but we cannot mathematically prove AI is the sole isolated cause.
It is a vital guardrail. But even just as a descriptive map of employer behavior, finding that the within occupation channel is basically flat is a massive shock to the system.
And this is where we have to talk about the great disagreement. Because what you just said, that employers don't change the tasks inside an existing job, flies in the face of 20 years of accepted economic theory. I've been reading for years that jobs constantly evolve from the inside
out.
You have because of the foundational 2003 paper by Otter, Levy, and Murnane. They established the entire task approach to labor economics.
Right. They proved that computers substitute for routine tasks and complement non-routine ones.
Yes, but their crucial finding was that more than half of the demand shift caused by computerization happened within nominally identical occupations.
And didn't Adelaide's team find the exact same thing in 2020? They looked at a century of newspaper job ads and they concluded that a substantial fraction of task change happened inside narrowly defined job titles that never changed their names.
Both of those foundational papers tell us the within occupation channel is where all the action is.
So I have to push back here. How can two decades of Nobel tier economic theory say the action is inside the job title? But this brand new data set of 750 million ads says the action inside the title is totally flat.
Who is wrong?
That is honestly the most exciting mystery in labor economics today. It's not necessarily that someone is wrong. It's about the context of what is being measured. We have three main theories for the discrepancy.
OK, let's hear them.
The first is the time horizon. Otter and Adelaide were looking at decades of relatively slow technology adoption. The PC revolution took a long time to permeate an office.
Okay, I can see that. A manager in 1995 had five years to slowly teach their secretary how to use Excel, so the secretary's job evolved internally. But this new paper is looking at just 32 months, from 2022 to 2026, of a violent,
rapid, generative AI shock.
Exactly. Maybe employers simply don't have the time to slowly rewrite job descriptions. The velocity of the shock might dictate the mechanism of adjustment.
Makes total sense. What's the second theory?
The outcome being measured. The older papers were often looking at broad survey data or realized employment over years. This new paper is measuring real time posted vacancies.
So it's entirely possible that employers experiment with new occupational structures in their job ads long before the actual employment statistics catch up.
Precisely. And the third theory is geography. Could this simply be a structural difference between the U.S. labor market and the Chinese labor market?
I mean, it's highly probable. China has historically compressed a century of structural economic change into just two generations. Entire industries appear and shrink at a pace that mature Western economies rarely experience.
So the mechanism of adjustment in China might structurally rely more on swapping out entire occupations rather than internal task rewriting.
But the data doesn't give us a definitive answer to which theory is right, does it?
No, it just leaves the door genuinely open for us to figure out.
Which honestly highlights the immense danger of relying on static definitions of work. It reminds me of that famous 2017 paper by Frey and Osborne.
The one that predicted 47% of U.S. employment was at risk of computer automation.
Right, but they computed that risk at the occupation level. They looked at 702 specific occupations, treated them as single, solid objects, and assigned them a probability of doom.
And this new data set proves precisely why collapsing an occupation to a single point is so mathematically dangerous.
Because if you just look at production worker as a single data point, you miss the staircase. You average out the low wage worker doing manual assembly with the high wage worker doing process coordination.
Exactly. When you rely on averages, the spread and the nuance of how the technology actually interacts with human labor just vanish.
So to synthesize this journey, an occupation is not a static title printed on a cardboard box. It is a living, breathing distribution of tasks and requirements. And that distribution shifts violently based on your wage, your city, and the rapidly changing winds of technology.
Which is why having a monthly employer-written vocabulary is such a huge leap forward. But we should be clear, this doesn't make our older curated systems obsolete. Take OneNet, for example, the occupational database run by the
U.S. government.
Right, which relies on expert surveys and updates very slowly. I would assume the authors of this new paper want to replace things like OneNet.
Actually, no. The authors explicitly state this new method is a complement to OneNet, not a substitute. OneNet gives us three decades of historical comparability. You absolutely need that long-term baseline to understand macroeconomic trends.
But this new posting-based method gives us the real-time, month-by-month pulse.
Exactly.
We also need to be brutally honest about the limits of scanning job ads. Online postings are not a perfect mirror of the real economy. They heavily overrepresent urban, formal, white-collar, and service jobs.
Right. If you are an agricultural worker or working in the informal economy, your job probably isn't being posted on a major digital recruitment platform.
And as we touched on, a posting is an advertisement. It's an employer's fantasy wish list, not a finalized hire. Plus, the LLM exposure scores they calculated are fundamentally frozen in time.
That's a great point. They are based on what AI models could do at the exact moment the scoring was done.
Yeah.
As models get smarter, those exposure scores will become outdated.
But the brilliance of the architecture they built, the reusable cookie cutter, is that recalculating those scores won't cost them another 9.7 million yuan. They can rerun the taxonomy against the new AI capabilities affordably.
It truly is a genuine triumph of data science.
So we started today by talking about that closed cardboard box with your job title written on the side. We've ripped it open and we've discovered that the contents, the specific tasks you know how to do, are surprisingly durable, even as employers throw the box itself in the trash.
The tasks outlive the jobs that carry them.
So I want to leave you with a final thought to mull over. If tasks truly outlive the jobs that carry them, what happens to your career if your job title completely disappears tomorrow, but the specific tasks you are a master of are suddenly
scattered across three entirely different, newly invented occupations? Are you spending your energy right now preparing to defend a dying job title, or are you building a resilient portfolio of tasks?
That really is the question of the decade.
Thanks for diving deep with us today.